you're going to be turning 75 you
redefine
what that means as you reach each
milestone
age i want to know what
impact if any does the number have on
you
i don't think about my life in terms of
numbers first of all
i ain't never going to be old because i
ain't got time to be old i can't stop
long enough to grow old
i'm just going to be the best i can be
at whatever age i
am and i bet you i won't look much
different when i'm 95 if i live that
long because i'm like the gabor sisters
i'm going to look like a cartoon i'll
have all the makeup
i'll look as young as my plastic
surgeons will allow me
and it's like all in makeup and lighting
and all that but i think more than
anything
it's about what comes from inside you
it's an attitude and
you know you gotta shine from within and
sometimes that can
make you feel young and make you seem
young to other people
you know i what i love about you every
time i've ever talked with you
over the years and you're on the oprah
show multiple times
you have never been one of those women
who has been reluctant to talk about
plastic surgery
do you know how old you were when you
first started getting plastic surgery i
think about 40
really i think i started uh yeah i
started thinking when i was about 40 i
i need a few little nips and tucks and
little pulls and sucks and whatever
we get you know because i i'm a firm
believer
whatever it takes to make you feel
better about yourself if you've got the
nerve
and if you got the money and uh you know
and you got
the need for it if it's going to make
you feel better about yourself if you
feel good about you
you can make people feel better about
themselves because you feel good
and you always felt good you always felt
good i remember you know obviously times
have changed but
you obviously remember years ago when
men on television would make jokes about
your curvy figure
about your boobs about your wigs and you
once told bobber walters that the joke
was on them because
you knew exactly what you were doing
with your image were you ever
hurt though by any of those jokes or did
you always know
that you had created this image and that
is
that was a part of where you were headed
that was a part of your own marketing
well in my head i knew where uh where i
was
headed because to me i'm not a natural
beauty and i was always i wanted to be
pretty
i was that backwards barbie i was i was
impressed with that
and i just always felt more inside than
how i looked on the outside so
i really patterned my look after the
town [ __ ]
in our in our hometown the trollop you
know the one that would kind of walk
them down the streets and get in the car
and ride off for a few minutes come back
and
get in another car you know we i didn't
know anything about that part then
i just knew she was beautiful she had
all this beautiful blonde hair red
lipstick and
makeup tight short skirts and
high-heeled shoes and
i just thought she was the prettiest
thing i'd ever seen so i kind of
patterned my look after that i always
loved the fredericks of hollywood
magazines you know that was just kind of
to me how i
felt like i wanted to look so in the
early days
uh to answer your uh first part of your
question
i think it used to bother me that you
know when people
i mean it didn't didn't change me it
didn't make me do it different
but i kind of get a little embarrassed
sometimes if somebody made too much
fun of it but i that was when i knew
they didn't know who all i was
you